most people don't even know this
industry exists that people fly in
airplanes that are flying yachts so we
do everything from taking delivery at
the OEM the OEM being Boeing or Airbus
or whoever the manufacturer might be and
then we'll go ahead and do the interior
the engineering the design will
fabricate all the parts we do all the
cabinet making here the finishing here
the sheetmetal here we do every aspect
of the aircraft right up to the delivery
so we can take you from cradle to grave
clients want to have high end amenities
in their aircraft I'd like to do like a
lacquer we start off with developing a
floor plan then from there we'll create
a 3d model of it almost anything is
possible if it's alligator skin seats a
first skin pro we provide whatever they
want I think one of the craziest things
that has been thought about putting a
waterfall inside of an airplane our
clients it's an interesting mix it's all
over the board between corporations and
you might have the chairman's area in
the back where he's got a bedroom a
small office a shower where he can come
off the airplane refreshed in the main
cabin the seats will turn into beds you
can have a conference table where people
can work so it's a working aircraft then
you have some people that just want
their privacy they want to know that
they can go from where they live toward
a vacation from Santa Barbara it's a
nice they want to fly non-stop so they
cater their aircraft to their needs and
their family it's a really a sense of
pride to see the airplane leave and take
off and then you got to go back and do
it all over again